sin oxígeno así se están quedando
decenas de pacientes en los hospitales
de manaus en la amazonía de brasil el
sistema de salud local está colapsando
otra vez como ocurrió en abril los
centros de salud envían a hospitalizados
a otras ciudades el ejército llevó
suplementos luego de que el estado de
amazonas le hiciera un llamado urgente y
las autoridades decretaron un toque de
queda de 11 horas en manaos entre las 19
y las 6 de la mañana pero para muchos
las medidas llegan tarde como para mail
y quien perdió a su abuela por la
escasez de implementos y por ello salió
a protestar
mi abuela murió hoy por falta de oxígeno
y sus pajes había 21 pacientes en la uci
divididos en grupos iguales y mi abuela
de 84 años no pudo sobrevivir
necesitaba 15 litros de oxígeno por
minuto pero no había suficiente
investigadores creen que el nuevo
repunte del cobi 19 en amazonas se debe
en parte a la variante del virus que se
descubrió en el estado brasileño y que
las autoridades confirmaron esta semana
pero para el ministerio de salud la
crisis sanitaria es porque los
hospitales no trataron los pacientes a
tiempo
manaus no debí
manaos no contaba con un plan de acción
efectivo para el tratamiento temprano
con diagnóstico clínico atención básica
y eso ha afectado mucho en la gravedad
del virus y su impacto mundo a gravedad
aguda durante esta semana japón confirmó
cuatro casos de la variante de brasil y
reino unido prohibió los vuelos
provenientes del país y de sudamérica
por la misma razón mientras que algunos
brasileños en otras ciudades temen que
la mutación se propague con la revisión
de pacientes provenientes de manaos